hi I'm Gail Miller be sure the voice of
the Westminster Kennel Club and this is
every single breed of dog
there are 205 breeds so that we're going
to go over
so grab your lead your bait and let's
head out to the show floor the 205
breeze that we're looking at are all a
KC recognized breeds that means the
American Kennel Club has deemed these
breeds as eligible to show at a KC
recognized dog shows such as the
Westminster Kennel Club today we have
seven groups hound toy non-sporting
herding working Terrier and sporting the
groups are determined by the original
function the dog was bred for we have a
couple of them put together in subgroups
that's because there's something that
relates these breeds in some way it
might be country of origin it may be
coat texture or may be temperament there
are hundreds of breeze across the world
that aren't even in the United States
but as they become popular in the US
that's when they're added to a KC
recognition and that's when they can
show at dog shows and have to fit into
one of these groups hurting their
thirty-one breeds in the herding group
the herding group is comprised of breeds
that were moving livestock from one
point to another it might be sheep it
might be cattle that is their main goal
is to make sure they're helping humans
keep their livestock safe and keep them
moving originally herding breeds were
part of the working group and then in
1983 because there were so many dogs in
the working group they split off the
herding breeds and formed the herding
group the Australian Cattle Dog the
Australian Shepherd in the miniature
American Shepherd are grouped here
because they're all hard-working herding
breeds the Australian Cattle Dog
originally from Australia is known as a
wonderful breed for cattle they're
really known to be brave cows are
kicking the dogs have to be fast they
have to be determined and they cannot be
swayed by a kicking
the Australian Shepherd actually is a
misnomer they're not from Australia
they're actually were developed in the
western part of the United States by
ranchers they're a wonderful hurting dog
that has a strong Drive just like the
Australian Cattle Dog the miniature
American Shepherd is actually just a
smaller version of the Australian
Shepherd the ranchers wanted something a
little smaller is a little more portable
and that they could use in quick ways
and it's become highly popular with city
dwellers the subgroup of the bearded
collie and border collie is that they're
both from Scotland their Scottish
herding breeds and the bearded collie
has much more profuse coat they were in
a cold temperature whereas the border
collie was as the name says on the
border of Scotland and England and both
of them are great herding dogs but they
have very different hurting styles they
have a double coat they come in four
different colors fawn brown black and
blue there's regular grooming with that
long coat but they're versatile and they
participate in all dog sports this
subgroup is what we call the Belgian
group so these obviously are all from
Belgium but they have different coat
textures and they have a different
coloring and the reason is they're from
different regions in Belgium they would
have different needs of coat texture and
type based on the terrain based on the
weather and the conditions that the dog
would be working the Belgian Malinois
has become very popular with the police
and with military use they can be very
focused and highly trainable and very
quick to move and very in tune with
their handler the Belgian sheepdog is
all black there again a very
serious-minded dog they're a
hard-working dog there are large size
though I mean this is the type of thing
you have to take into consideration
their larger than the Malinois the
Belgian tervuren has a double coat as
well they often have that reddish color
a mahogany color with the black overlay
black mask
upright ears one thing you notice with
all three of these breeds is they don't
have a long stride in their gait they
have a powerful gait that can go all day
and that's a very unique part of these
three breeds I'll talk about how the
dogs gait differently the gait is how
they trot and there's a different trot
based on the dogs function sometimes
they have to have
stilted gate in the back that means
they're pushing their a sled dog or a
dog that's pulling bone structure is
such that they can push easily there are
other breeds like herding breeds some
that have a lot of extension and their
gait and that's so they can cover a lot
of ground in a short amount of time then
there are other dogs that have a medium
stretch of gait the endurance gate so
they can continue all day long and work
all day long here we have the beauceron
we have the barre JP car the Bouvier des
Flanders and the Briard and of course
these are all very different looking
dogs that's because they have different
functions that beauceron it's a little
more protective very obedient very
gentle the bearish ap car has that
tousle look it's a very wiry coat
they're supposed to be very natural in
this show they're not supposed to be
trimmed and soft furred they're supposed
to be rough-and-tumble the Bouvier des
Flandres similar to the Old English
Sheepdog was a drover they definitely or
on watch could be used as a guardian a
flock and home they are also a large
size so they could also be used to pull
carts if needed and then you have the
Briard they are a wonderful herding
breeds of French breed known for its
upright year carriage which it gives it
an interesting look to the face and head
shape here we have the cardigan west
Corgi and the Pembroke Welsh Corgi as
the name implies they're both from Wales
the Queen is very well known for having
corgis if you look in the head shape the
head size the body shape in the front
they're very different begin there for
livestock mostly cattle having that low
center of gravity cow kicks its hoof out
back the dog is low and back far enough
that it can't get hit another thing
that's interesting is both these dogs
have the flat head especially the
Pembroke has a flat top skull so that if
it does get kicked by a cow it won't
hurt the dog's skull here we have the
rough collie which is the coated one the
smooth collie
and then the Shetland Sheepdog which
isn't a collie but look
like a miniature collie oftentimes
people think this Sheltie is just a
miniaturized collie but it is a separate
breed so the collie of course became
famous when lassie has TV show and they
were actually entered the Westminster
Dog Show in the 1800s JP Morgan had his
colleagues at our dog show the smooth
Holly as the name of is they have a
smoother coat the reason is of course
temperature you may be in the debris
moles of Scotland you don't want to have
to worry about that coat getting tangled
up so here you have a nice smooth breed
if you're a shepherd you don't want to
have to worry about grooming your dog
you want to make sure your dogs are
happy and healthy then there's the
Shetland Sheepdog now Shetland Sheepdog
is such a trainable awesome breathe that
they're in so many different sports they
excel in agility obedience you see them
everywhere and that's because they want
to please their owners like most herding
breeds the next subgroup is the
Scandinavian breeds and parse these all
were herding dogs but they heard in
different ways and in different climates
that would account for why their size
and their coats are different there's
the finnish lapland who has a little
thicker coat we have the Norwegian woman
who is a shorter coat and always a black
mask and then we have this Swedish
valium was a little lower to the ground
because he was working cattle here we
have the two Hungarian breeds that are
known for being really tough herding
dogs they don't take any guff from
anybody they may look cute and fluffy
but believe me they are serious the Puli
head can be corded or not corded and the
Pumas characteristic feature is those
high gears that are lifted up and looks
super cute then they have a very soft
coat that's a single coat don't be
fooled that is a very serious herding
dog the Burger Moscow is known as
working very closely with its owner they
sometimes can be a little suspicious of
others that's what they're originally
bred to do is work with the shepherd and
to make sure that their flock is safe
they have a very thick corded coat it's
made of three different types of hair
the Kanan dog has a very strong
effortless gait and they're known fail
to cover ground and an effortless manner
Old English Sheepdog is known as a
drover which means they weren't
necessarily running all day to capture
or bring back a loose sheep what they
were really used for is keeping the
flock together and moving them down the
road maybe they're taking them to the
market for sale maybe they're moving
them to another paddock but it's really
just driving the Sheep versus herding
the sheep which is a great skill to have
the ently Bouguer mountain dog is the
smallest of the for swiss breeds the
German Shepherd dog has long been a
favorite of family and police and
military they're very courageous they
have an exceptional train ability
they're very versatile they're very
attentive and what they're most known
for is their work ethic they will not
slow down on the job they're always
ready to go ready for action they were
very unique gate and originally they
were called a living fence because they
would trot around the entire flock to
keep it safe what's interesting with the
German Shepherd is if they need to then
move into action they can switch gears
very quickly and become powerful
trotters instantly to get to where they
need to be they continue to help man in
many different capacities even our best
in show winner rumor who won in 2017 has
now gone on and had litters of puppies
she has two puppies right now that have
been placed with veterans with PTSD
vice landok sheepdog is Iceland's only
native dog and they've appeared on their
postage stamps they come in two types of
coat the the long-haired and the short
hand the Polish lowland sheepdog is very
similar looking to the bearded collie
and they have a very different coat
texture there may be some polish lowell
in behind the bearded collie several
centuries back but they are different
breeds and they have different
temperaments the Polish lowland is a
little more suspicious they're a little
more cautious whereas the bearded collie
is generally jumping up on people and
very out
going the per Indian Shepherd is
supposed to be shown in a very natural
state they're supposed to be rough and
rugged they have a harsh coat that is
important for the job in the location
where they would work
they are wonderful breed a great size
and they can be in city or country the
Spanish water dog has a very curly coat
and as the name says that they worked in
water and on land is general farm dog
many people think that this is one of
the original breeds behind many of
today's water breeds count the Hound
group is the largest group with 32
breeds
and these are broken out basically by
the scent hounds and the sight hounds so
the first subgroup has the Afghan hound
the Saluki the oz walk and also the
slooghi and these are all breeds that
were with desert nomads traveling they
were hunting things out in the desert
and they are super super fast
these are sight hounds they can see a
hare a human cannot see and they can go
out and be independent hunters work away
from the people and bring down that game
the first pair of Afghan hounds were
brought to United States by Zeppo Marx
the Oz walk this breed is a
smooth-coated very tall sighthound
they're rather aloof is a lot of pounds
are but they make wonderful companions
when you watch a Saluki go around the
ring at the Westminster Kennel Club dog
show you'll see an elegant effortless
date they have a feathering on their
legs and on their ears they're very
independent they're very beautiful
they're very elegant and dignified the
Saluki first will appeared at
Westminster in 2017 this is a very fast
smooth-coated sighthound
that sometimes is hard to say the name
but it is a graceful and noble green the
next subgroup is the American Fox hound
the English Fox had and the Harrier
there's slight differences in these
three dogs the American Fox hound is
taller on leg has
little narrower head the English
Foxhound is a little sturdier a little
thicker has a wider skull and that of
course the Harrier is also has more
substance but it's smaller overall and
so the hunters use these dogs based on
where they're hunting and what their
needs are so a taller leg dog may be
useful if you're going through brush
whereas the shorter dog might be when
you're on an open field here we have the
basset hound the bloodhound and the
otter hound and the one thing these
three all have in common are the very
long hound ears those ears aren't just
cute and wonderful to hold there's a
purpose the purpose is to bring in scent
so when the dog's head is on the ground
sniffing and trying to follow a scent
the ears actually help collect scent and
help the dog follow the otter hand of
course is interesting because he's in
the water a lot and he has webbed feet
for that form follows function these
dogs are shaped and have these features
based on what their jobs were here we
have the beagles the 15 inch and the 13
inch so everyone knows that beagles are
so friendly and outgoing that because
they are a pack animal and they have to
be able to get along with other dogs and
people and work for humans together
that's part of the reason beagles have
always been a favorite in the United
States here we have the american english
hound the black-and-tan hound
the bluetick coonhound the Redbone
Coonhound and the treeing walker
coonhound and then of course there's the
plot hound which is named after a person
so the bluetick coonhound is known by
the ticking in the coat that means the
little dots the little spots and that
bluish tone to it it's beautiful coat
and then the red bone it's a beautiful
red color of varying shades now if you
saw the dogs next to each other you'd
notice more than just a coat difference
they also have different head shapes
they have different substance different
wound around a bone and that's because
it depends on the hunting conditions
they would be used in now the dachshunds
have a lot of variety because there's
two sizes the miniature and the standard
and then there's three coat varieties
the long hair the smooth coat and the
wire hair so there's a little bit of
something for everyone and they have
different temperaments the wire hair is
a more Terrier like these
coats are the original hound and so they
are more of a hound independent thinker
and then the long hairs are a little
sweeter I would say a little more I'm
wanting to be in your lap companion and
that's probably because they're spaniel
introduced when the long coat was needed
you may ask why do you need three
different coats the reason is again it's
temperature weather if you have a colder
temperature you want a dog that has fur
on it so that it can keep hunting and
these dogs as they said before are very
independent thinkers they were not
unlike the herding breeds who worked
with man these work with humans but they
worked away from them they didn't take
direct commands they would go out and
find the Badgers the hair and different
rabbits and different small game and
then they would follow that vermin into
the ground under in tunnels they have to
be very bold to go in a dark tunnel
after a badger and then they would bark
until the hunter found them and could
get the quarry underground so they're
supposed to be bold they're supposed to
be barky and they're supposed to be
independent thinkers here we have the
grandpa say griffall vonda y'all and the
petit bus a griffons LD all they're very
similar-looking tasseled rough-looking
dogs with the long ears obviously the
broad is bigger and the petite is
smaller but there are other differences
the grande it has a lot more girth to it
they have a different temperament
somewhat again these are pack animals so
they're very outgoing and happy and
loving dogs they were bred to work with
other dogs but it depended on the job if
you need a big one use the big one if
you need a small one you use the small
now the feral hound and the abhi thin
hound both like to compete and say their
dogs are the ones that are at the
entrance of the tombs in Egypt I'm not
sure which what it is we don't know
they are both ancient ancient breed the
pharaoh hound is known to blush and turn
a little pink in its cheeks and nose
when it's excited or anxious the
Chernenko del Etna however is much
smaller than the other two but as a very
similar outline in that classic look
that you
see that it looked like it may have been
Egypt at some point here we have the
Irish Wolfhound
the Scottish Deerhound and the borzoi
which used to be called the Russian will
have these large breeds have greyhound
behind them at some point they're very
fast they can take down large game
they're known for taking down Wolf's elk
deer anything of larger size that might
be near to the castle or might be a
predator of some kind they were there to
guard and to hunt with noblemen they've
been part of the castle as they said
they weren't necessarily out in the barn
these were house dogs here we have the
greyhound and the whipping they look
very similar to each other yet they are
very distinct breeds the whippets head
is very different shape than the
greyhound but they are both wonderful
pets they're super fast so if you're
going to have one at home you have to
make sure you have a yard or always keep
them on leave because otherwise if they
got away from you they can keep going
what's interesting is most greyhound
people say that their dogs are couch
potatoes in the house they really just
like to lounge around but what's outside
if they see something they're gonna go
after it
the Basenji is an African breed with
ringtail and it's known as the barkless
dog although it does make sounds but
it's not known as the typical Barker the
new Asian elk hound has a very thick
coat and the name is actually a little
misleading because they didn't hunt elk
they hunted moose the Portuguese Podengo
pequenos
was a great little family dog they're so
fun and feisty and ready for action
they're also known as the national dog
of Portugal the Rhodesian Ridgeback has
become more popular in the United States
in the last 10 years they're beautiful
outline they're known for that Ridge of
fur on their back that goes the wrong
direction
they're known as being stoic and very
brave but you have to be if you're a
lion hunter in Africa they were known to
keep lions at bay for the
non-sporting in the beginning there was
the Sporting Group and the non-sporting
group and so if you weren't a setter or
spaniel you were put into this group the
Boston Terrier the Bulldog and the
French Bulldog these are all bull dog
related breeds and they all have that
really cute kind of smushed face a
shorter muzzle is what it actually is
and for the Bulldogs they were bred in
England as bull Bader's the dogs would
latch on to the bull and their strong
jaws would clamp on and they would
release when the owner said release now
they're just the cute lovable mascot of
many sports teams the French Bulldog of
course is very popular part of that is
because of its bat shaped ears they also
have a very round face they're a sturdy
little dog they love to go places they
love people they kind of snort and
sneeze and something very cute about
them that people love here we have the
Chinese shar-pei
and the Chow Chow both from China these
breeds very different coats the shar-pei
has almost a sandpaper feel to it and
the chow chow generally has a very thick
coat and so when you're brushing that
dog out you have to make sure you get
all the way down to the skin here we
have the Bichon Frise and the coton de
Tulear the Bichon Frise won Best in Show
at Westminster most recently in 2018
that was Fleming at the coton is the
Royal dog of Madagascar
here we have the Dalmatian and the show
Loic squealing now the reason I put
these two together is because they're
both very popular in their original
countries and because they've both
become superstars from Disney films the
Dalmatian of course is original coach
dog who is in 101 Dalmatians and the
Xolo was featured in the recent Pixar
film Coco
here we have the finnish spitz in the
keys haand these are both spits breathes
meaning they have two upright ears they
have a box-like face and the keys on of
course has a much thicker coat it's
similar to a Chacho in that it's a thick
double coat interestingly they have a
black mask and looks like they're
wearing spectacles and they're called
The Laughing Dutchman because when they
open their mouth it looks like they're
smiling this was a barge dog that was
used as an all-round guard dog rat or
whatever you needed it for this was an
all-purpose dog if you want to bring a
finnish spitz into your home make sure
you have a fenced yard or keep that dog
on leash they're known to want a row
here we have the miniature poodle and
the standard poodle in the non-sporting
group and of course the standard poodle
is known for being one of the most
trainable and human-like dogs in the dog
world sometimes people wonder why their
coat is clipped as it is and it's
important remember that the standard
poodle was originally a water retrieving
dog and so the pompons on its joints on
its hips and around its vital organs
were left on there to help keep the dog
warm in chilly water whereas the rest of
the coat was removed so the dog would
flow through the water easily the
miniature poodle is the medium-sized
poodle there's the standard miniature
and then the toy poodle in the toy group
here we have the Tibetan Spaniel and the
Tibetan Terrier obviously two breeds
from Tibet very different jobs but both
of them are known for being Hardy and
being very serious breeds the Tibetan
Spaniel makes a wonderful City dog there
are easy to grew they're easy to
transport
so the Tibetan Terrier and the show ring
has a long thick coat but if you want
one as a pet you don't have to keep that
long
you can clip it back and still enjoy the
great features of that breed the
American Eskimo was known as a circus
stock it's very trainable it's cute it
can learn things quickly and they're
very popular lots of dog sports the
Lhasa Apso is a wonderful lap dog today
as it was centuries ago this breed was a
guard dog in palaces but also a faithful
companion the Lhasa Apso was the first
Tibetan breed to be recognized by the
American Kennel Club the Lau Ching can
come in all kinds of colors they have
that feature of the tail over the back
but it's a teacup handle they're fun
affectionate little breed they're
Norwegian Linda Hood has some very
unique features they have six toes they
have a very flexible neck and all of
this is so that they can hunt puffins
that's what they were originally bred to
do the skipper key is a copy little
compact dog all in black always alert
and ready to go the Shiba Inu is a very
popular breed in Japan and they're
gaining popularity in the United States
they're quiet and demeanor they're very
clean often called cat light
[Music]
you